I'm being honest I have zero faith in
the audience I assume audiences are all
incredibly unfunny and incredibly dumb
and I have to I spell out every joke
because there's other words works than
having a great idea and then I'm not
getting it so you've got to make them
understand it you know so I say it over
and over a million times and I just keep
trying to simplify simplify simplify and
take out everything you don't need and
shorten it up because I also have no
faith in people's attention span so it's
just years of hammering it through like
a funny filter or a simple filter you
got to drop them greg Giraldo said you
got to kill your babies it's hard but
I've seen comics in New York doing the
same bit and it's bombs every goddamn
time and they keep doing it and it makes
you look worse and it also makes you
look crazy like you're going what are
you trying to get out of this bit it
never has worked once get rid of it
but I know it's hard we're so attached
and we took the time to write it so it's
so hard to let it go but if you truly
believe in it I would put it aside as I
said fall out of love with it or become
a better writer over time and then
revisit it and you can really look at it
from a clear eye and go that's what I
was missing that's it I missed that one
little angle and that changed the whole
bit so you really believe in it put it
in the drawer come back in a year I
almost have to tweak those to perfection
in your apartment before you can
actually get a laugh at it a joke has to
be pitch perfect before it'll work
because the subject matter is so edgy
how do you get it right oh and your
apartment alone without an audience
because you still bombed with it you
gotta just suck it up and bomb with it
and just get little bits of information
from the audience every time it bombs
like all right I did a little better if
I say it that way if I say it faster it
does better or if I just lean into it it
got a little bit better and then over
time gets with those little clues I
could get it to work a hundred percent
but it took a lot of trial and error of
just Guinea pigging that bit over and
over let me try it little this way let
me try that way we tried it and it took
forever but I finally got it I asked
everybody when I would start no because
I was like what the hell is your voice
what is that why is why is everybody
found theirs and I haven't found mine
and somebody told me I forgot who but
somebody gave me the great advices look
at all your jokes at work and find the
common link between all those jokes and
that's probably your voice why do you
keep going back to these why is this
subject matter touchdown a lot why is
this like this why'd you pick that butts
here whatever it is and that helped me
and listening yourself and you go oh
that's a that's a joke I would tell or
you listen to your friends I go that's
such a mark joke that's a and you're
like really and then you go okay so what
the hell's Mark what the hell is that
you know and just it's all about clues
and remembering everything take it all
in so for me I figured out eventually
that my stick is it's basically saying
if this is like that then why isn't this
like that and that's why I will act yeah
nice I don't see color
well then I'm black no you're not you
know inconsistencies I mean even David
tells like the funniest guy on the
planet he's got a [ __ ] jokes his his
he's got clean he can write clean he can
do it so I think it's imperative if you
want to do balland you want to do all
these late nights you got to have it so
it's a good way to get in the door I'm
not saying it to you might saying it's
your voice or your path
Rutherford forever but I think it's good
to have and [ __ ] it suck it up and and
try to make it work like let's say
you're an amazing wrestler and you want
to do the MMA you got to learn boxing
you got a box a little so have it in
your corner you know I'm not saying it's
got to be your future career what's the
opposite of temporary permanent thank
you say your permanent world but try it
knock it out and it's harder it is
harder I will say as a comic I can't
clean it's harder dirty is easier if I'm
saying dirty is bad I'm not saying the
dirty tack but it's easier because next
we're gonna laugh cursing we're gonna
laugh so challenge yourself by trying to
write some clean yeah
if you didn't have clean you wouldn't be
able to open for a Seinfeld exactly hit
exactly and I trust me I had to sift
through albums of stuff to find the
cleanest [ __ ] that's like his level
clean and I'm tell you what I'm glad
ahead if you're serious about becoming a
comedian join our Facebook group linked
in the description below to start
getting tips like these every single day
and watch this playlist of our top
writing tips to improve your writing
today